what he called out Steve Harvey he said
that he gave up standup because of all
the TV shows the seven shows or whatever
yeah he goes well you gave up stand up
before those seven shows you gave up
because you tried to go toe to- Toe with
me and I [__] Expos you for your
Baldhead did you see that Detroit clip
no I never saw first time I heard of it
so I youtubed it do you think that [__]
wanted to be here with me this evening
start January try to find his hair piece
and his career cuz I come to put that
[__] on the ground that's what a
championship is
it was a real thing that apparently
Steve Harvey went in didn't take it
seriously and then Cat Williams comes up
next and just [__] destroys him and
he says that's when you quit comedy and
I believe that